hallo mein Name ist Vanessa und ich bin
laktoseintolerant da muss man was machen
wenn auch du Laktose intolerant bist
wird dir dieses Video vielleicht
gefallen denn heute teste ich alle
laktosefreien Produkte die ich im
Supermarkt finden konnte und damit meine
ich wirklich alle Produkte die ich
finden konnte tatsächlich sind gar nicht
so viele wie ich dachte die war ein
bisschen enttäuscht ich habe im Alltag
noch nie eins dieser Produkte gegessen
denn ich esse dann meistens vegane
Schokolade oder wenn ich wirklich ein
Kinderriegel oder so haben möchte dann
haue ich mir so eine Laktase Tablette
rein was aber jetzt wirklich nicht oft
vorkommt weil ich auch das Gefühl habe
dass selbst diese Tabletten nicht so
wirklich funktioniert und das ist
eigentlich auch schon das Prinzip wie
diese Süßigkeiten funktioniert also da
ist einfach Laktase drin ach
so vielleicht haben sie einfach so eine
Prinzenrolle aufgemacht ein bisschen
Laktase darüber gestreut sich schön
zugemacht und verkaufst der todesfreie
Produkte sind echt teurer als normale
aber das ist auch wie bei glutenfrei und
fructosefrei das kostet halt mehr das
ist jetzt wirklich keine Werbung außer
bei food möchte unbedingt mit Werbung
machen dann können wir das gerne tun
aber es wäre schön dass wie waipude halt
andere Produkte auch einfach Laktase
reinmachen würden dann könnte man das
halt einfach essen trinken als Laktose
intoleranter Mensch aber das gibt's halt
echt selten ich glaube noch diese
Protein Puddings von Ehrmann oder so
haben die also mit Laktase da und jetzt
wird ganz kurz wissenschaftlich Freunde
der Sonne nur durch einen Tee ich
erkläre euch jetzt was Laktase ist euer
Magen-Darm-Bereich irgendwo hier ist
eine Bauchspeicheldrüse oder irgendwas
anderes und daraus kommt Laktase und
diese Laktase hilft dann der Laktose
sich zu spalten oder so irgendwas
passiert damit der Laktose naja und mit
der Zeit baut der Körper immer weniger
Laktase so dass er die Laktose
verarbeiten kann und bei manchen Leuten
passiert halt früher oder ist schon
immer so und deswegen sind sie schon
immer laktoseintolerant und deswegen
Kinder kann es auch sein dass wenn
jemand eine leckere Kugel Eis ist danach
ganz schön Bauchschmerzen bekommen
kriegen komisch das ist aber so und
jetzt geht's los mit dem Test unser
erster Kandidat ist das glauben wir Eis
von der Marke doof garen und hier stehts
drauf laktosefrei Eis ist das was ich am
allermeisten vermisse an einem schönen
Sommertag sich eine Kugel Eis seine
Eisdiele holen und ja ich weiß es gibt
so wie Eis aber noch 5 Jahren will man
einfach mal wieder nicht Zitrone oder
Himbeere Essen ich will Cookies sein
also irgendwie wundert mich nicht dass
das so ein Ostblock Eis ist das könnte
auch etwas sein was es genau so in Polen
gab no Front das sieht aber noch aus
Blog aus
die Sahne kickt
meine Bewertung jetzt hat noch nichts
mit dem eigentlichen Geschmack zu tun es
ist einfach gerade so geil ich jetzt
nicht gedacht also sechs extrem lecker
aber da wurde ich auch schon wieder so
traurig im Supermarkt diese Marke hat
jetzt auch so eine Eiscreme Torte im
Tiefkühlfach mit Bubblegum Geschmack
oder so es ist so un könnt ihr mich
einfach überall Laktase reinmachen ja
ich kann Laktase Tabletten nehmen ich
weiß aber es ist was anderes wenn das
schon so beigefügt ist die richtige
Menge damit sich das ausgleicht weil
dann sitze ich da zu Hause und denkt mir
so sehr soll ich jetzt eine Tablette
schmeißen wann soll ich sie schmeißen
das sollte ich jetzt vielleicht noch
eine zweite nehmen kann man überhaupt
das überdosieren und so kann es einfach
essen
das ist super schwer das zu bewerben
schaut euch mal dieses Eis an und jetzt
soll ich das eine 9 von 10 geben wo es
Sorten wie Magnum double Gold Karamell
solltet Macadamia Nuss gibt und dann
kommt das hier hallo ich bin frei
also dieses Eis ist schon gefährlich
lecker das hätte ich nicht entdecken
sollen das ist das ist nicht gut dass
ich das jetzt weiß das nächste Produkt
ist eine Ritter Sport Schokolade und sie
haben sich genau das gedacht warum
packen wir nicht einfach Laktase rein
ich weiß nicht ob es was am Geschmack
verändert ich finde laktosefreie Sahne
und Milch schmeckt z.B ganz normal meine
Schwiegermutter denkt aber bist du
kaputt in deinem Kopf und jedes Mal wenn
sie
Gericht kocht wo sie laktosefreie Sahne
rein macht sagt sie das schmeckt süß
aussehen tut's ganz normal die Ritter
Sport Vollmilch laktosefrei hat einen
Laktosegehalt von maximal 0,1 % bei der
Herstellung des Trockenmilch Erzeugnis
wird mich sogar mit Hilfe des Enzyms
Laktase in Glucose und galaktase
umgewandelt
als ob ich nicht nach diesem Video einen
Zuckerschock haben werde ich finde die
Schokolade mit dem besten Mundgefühl ist
immer noch Lindt Schokolade aber Ritter
Sport ist für mich schon leicht danach
oder das Milka mich würde mal
interessieren wie ihr Lindt Milka und
Ritter Sport Ranken würdet Lindt ist
aber auch verdammt teuer Reihenfolge
rein vom Geschmack Lindt Ritter Sport
Milka und die bekommt eine acht von zehn
ein originalproduktlose frei habe ich
noch lecker ich euch
also ähm was ist das ein Erdbeeren
Joghurt oder sind
Quark-Creme ich dachte das ist dieser
schaumige Quark
Joghurt Creme Erdbeeren nehme ich dass
ich solche Sachen essen kann ne das ist
ich es nie
ja Zeiten Fruchtzwerg laktosefreier der
nur ein bisschen hässlicher aussieht
oh ich habe sowas so lange nicht mehr
gegessen ich kann es verstehen wenn man
es seinem Kind gibt und denkt ja jetzt
kriegt halt so ein kleinen Joghurt 12 g
Zucker ich finde das Problem mit solchen
Produkten Joghurt Creme ist eine
Süßigkeit sowas habe ich früher zum
Frühstück gegessen und Cornflakes und so
der Haut man sich als Frühstück
Süßigkeiten rein schmeckt auch super
süßen auch nicht so lecker also das ist
nicht geil ich muss damit weitermachen
Doppel Kekse verstehe nicht welche
Kritikpunkte - er nimmt was für ein
Produkt sie rausbringen möchte
Doppelkekse das ist jetzt nicht was ich
jetzt Laktose intoleranter wirklich
vermisse also ich glaube es gibt coolere
Sachen die sie machen können als
Doppelkekse
was wird das hier für ein Video ich habe
schon wieder so ein Flashback zu dritte
Klasse waldtierpark Brotdose aufmachen
und zwei dieser Kekse finden und sich
richtig freuen
Prinzenrolle ist ja nicht ohne Grund zu
beliebt ne es erfüllt sein Zweck ages
aber es ist nicht was ich mir jetzt noch
mal holen würde sechs von zehn Punkten
oh noch eine sehr interessante Marke
Frankonia Laktose und Verträglichkeit
ist kein Grund auf Schokolade zu
verzichten diese zart schmelzen nämlich
Schokolade ist laktosefrei und bietet
unbeschwerden Genuss damit du dir danach
nicht in die Hose machst ja
milchcremesuppe das
auch Milchcreme Schokolade ist etwas was
ich seit 300 Jahren nicht mehr gegessen
und ich hasse es das Milka und die
ganzen anderen Marken jedes Jahr zu
Ostern und zu Weihnachten diese neuen
Produkte rausbringen mit so Eiern jetzt
mit Milchcreme zum Löffeln Milchcreme
hier Milchcreme da das ist so
deprimierend ich meine es auch gut für
meine Figur ich glaube wenn ich Laktose
vertragen würde würde ich so viel
Schokolade Eis und Torten essen
[Musik]
okay I don't like the packageing warum
ist das aussehen wie medizinisch warum
entscheiden sich alle laktosefreien
Produkte für die Farbe Blau das ist die
Schokolade richtig lecker zu halten wenn
sie in der Hand schmilzt Milchcreme
hallo
wow das Wichtige ist kann es mit sowas
wie Kinderschokolade mithalten
[Applaus]
zu eins wie Kinderschokolade
schmeckt wirklich wie Kinderschokolade
weil billige Milchcremefüllung zum
Beispiel so von Aldi und so hatte immer
so einen komischen Säure
-tann oh nein wer darf niemals
rausfinden dürfen Mist die super sehen
von zehn aber wieso die sieht so blöd
aus und dann aus dem Kühlschrank ich
liebe Schokolade aus dem Kühlschrank
gerade Milchcreme Schokolade muss aus
dem Kühlschrank sein Leben hat auch eine
Marke die Rewe frei von heiß und die ist
glutenfrei laktosefrei also es ist eher
glutenfrei laktosefreie Produkte habe
ich jetzt nur das hier gesehen das finde
ich immer so die haben Windbeutel von
dieser Marke und ich feiere jedes mal
drauf rein weil da steht vorne und dann
sind so Windbeutel drauf und dann denke
ich mir oh mein Gott ich kauf mir
Windbeutel aber die sind immer
glutenfrei denke mach doch ein bisschen
Laktase rein macht er doch noch geh doch
mal diesen extra Schritt viele Laktose
intolerante würden sich freuen
ich kann die sind alle so einzeln
verpackt ich vermute dass sie es wegen
diesem glutenfreien Aspekt machen aber
das sind das für eine Verpackung für
einen Keks ich weiß also super schmecken
wird er mir jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht
weil glutenfrei
hmm
der schmeckt viel zu
medizinisch medizinisch das schmeckt so
Glutenfreiheit ne sollte man ein Video
machen wo ich glutenfrei Produkte aus
teste ich habe eine Zeit lang nicht
glutenfrei ernährt weil ich dachte das
ist mein Problem mit meinem Körper als
ich diesen Helicobacter im Magen hatte
und das war schon hart ne also
glutenfreie Produkte vielleicht sind sie
mittlerweile besser geworden okay
Zuckerschock ist da wir geben Rewe frei
von noch eine Chance hier ist noch ein
Produkt eben hatten wir einen Cookie in
Schokostückchen jetzt haben wir
Schokolade mit Cookies Laktose und
glutenfrei ich habe jetzt ja die Ritter
Sport Schokolade probiert und die
Kinderschokolade okay
warum sind die alle so lecker acht von
zehn ganz kurz gedacht das ist ein Lindt
Schokolade aber das Design ne aber das
Design muss leicht so aussehen okay was
habe ich schon Keks Keks Schokolade
Schokolade Eis Schoko irgendwann später
machen weil ich so viel Süßes gegessen
habe dass ich dachte es reicht nein Timo
bitte auch laktosefrei Süßigkeiten
testen
ich bin ehrlich mit dir ich tue jetzt
einfach mal so als ob ich noch richtig
Bock hätte weiter Süßigkeiten zu essen
und es geht weiter mit einem
laktosefreien Bounty das ist kein Bounty
aber es ist ein kokosniegel ich liebe
den kokosfliege von Wiegens ich finde es
schmeckt wie Kokosbutter fest geworden
und man ist eigentlich ein Stück oder
mit Schokolade drum rum aber mit Bounty
hat er nicht viel zu tun und ich denke
vielleicht schon optisch schon mal eine
fünf von zehn geschmacklich
nein der schmeckt nicht schrecklich aber
er schmeckt nicht so dass man sich
darüber freut fünf oder sechs von zehn
minus 11 ist schon wieder ein Produkt
Butterkekse das andere waren Doppelkeks
Butterkeks der Doppelkeks war nicht so
geil aber vielleicht wird's ja der
Butterkeks designmäßig natürlich schon
meine zehn von zehn
die einzige Frage die wir uns hier
stellen müssen es ist fast so gut wie
leitness
ich habe immer das Gefühl hier steht
dann einfach irgendwann so
Leibnitzer GmbH Butter ist mit
Schokolade ich habe es jetzt den Slogan
von -l gelesen - L ich fühle mich wohl
das ist so eine schöne Umschreibung für
damit ich kein Durchfall kriege
die wird beim nächsten Ausflug ins
Schwimmbad auf jeden Fall geben
vorletztes Produkt weiße Schokolade das
ist eine Königsdisziplin weiße
Schokolade
schwer gut zu machen es gibt nur wenig
gute weiße Schokolade weil manchmal
schmeckt es dann zu sehr wie eine Butter
Zucker Mischung weiße Schokolade muss
dieses weiße Schokolade Aroma haben all
die macht keine oder früher hat Aldi
keine gute weiße Schokolade gemacht das
war die einzige Schokolade die wir
gekriegt haben oder manchmal die die
übrig bliebt von weißer Kuvertüre weiße
Kuvertüre ist lecker und anders wie bei
Zartbitterschokolade ist das natürlich
vollgepackt mit Milch hat
Bitterschokolade ist ja auch meistens
laktosefrei und vegan weil da einfach ja
keine Milch drin ist weil man da keine
Milch drin braucht aber weiß Schokolade
ist schwer
das hätte ich natürlich lesen sollen mit
Traubenzucker
Laktose und Fruchtzucker und
Verträglichkeit ist kein Grund um auf
Schokolade verzichten zu müssen Menschen
die Fructose Intoleranz sind die haben
mein größtes Beileid lass uns mal die
Unverträglichkeiten Ranken wir haben
Gluten Fructose und Laktose ich finde
laktosis ist das am wenigstens
schlimmsten weil dieses Enzym einfach
irgendwo rein gemacht werden kann und
dann hast du space oder Gluten ich
glaube Fructose ist das Schlimmste bei
Fructose in wirklich auch so viel Gemüse
und Obst drin ist und bei Gluten ja gut
dann kannst du halt kein Weizen es gibt
kein Grund warum ich mir das letzte
Produkt zum Schluss aufbewahrt hat
Nutella die keine Nutella ist ich meine
es gibt ganz viele Nuss Nougat Creme es
gibt nicht nur Nutella aber Nutella ist
aus meiner Erinnerung natürlich die
tollste Schokocreme und dafür muss ich
mir natürlich einen
los
diese laktosefreie hat so oben so eine
Kruste
wie viel Nougatcreme macht ihr euch da
eigentlich immer drauf Timo ballert da
immer so einen Berg drauf ich mache
immer nur so eine perfekte dünne Schicht
der perfekte Toast bitte bohre mir das
nutellaweibes gibt ne
am Anfang war ich nicht so begeistert
aber doch umso mehr ich das esse umso
besser wird ich habe nur den größten
Fehler gemacht dass ich mir diese ganzen
Produkte jetzt ins Haus geholt habe weil
jetzt gibt's keine Entschuldigung für
mich das nicht zu essen jetzt kann ich
das alles essen ohne Bauchschmerzen zu
kriegen diese Süßigkeiten Test Videos
ich habe schon wieder vergessen was für
eine über zuckererung ich da eigentlich
immer erlebe ich glaube ich werde auch
gleich wieder richtig tief einschlafen
weil und jetzt wird wieder
wissenschaftlich wenn man viel Zucker zu
sich nimmt dann geht er Insulinspiegel
hoch und der Glukose Spiegel nee der
Glukose Spiegel geht hoch und dann geht
er Insulinspiegel hoch und das
runterzuholen und dann geht das für
Kurse runter aber der Insulinspiegel ist
so hoch und dann crashen wir irgendwie
so mein Fazit ist kauft lieber vegane
Süßigkeiten aber wenn ihr dann doch mal
was wollt ihr was lecker schmeckt
Kinderschokolade vielen Dank für eure
Aufmerksamkeit ich hoffe euch hat das
Video Spaß gemacht wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder tschüss
[Musik]